come on
we can do this
we are outgunned the only way to catch
this crew is in the act
you're going new york
turn up the issue i'm dying to give you
the problem you practically begging for
it is the opinion of the department if
james knight wasn't hunting bank robbers
he'd be robbing thanks knight might be
rough around the edges
what is a good cop this crew is tight
they move like a team you got a theory
all roads lead back to a businessman
goes by winner
i hope i'm not uh interrupting what can
i do you for you know a lot of ex-pros i
like a couple of them for a messy job
do anything about that not to the best
of my recollection
think real hard
fbi cia atf all have open cases on
winners and two city cops from la walk
in here and they think they're gonna
handle this case
that cop served in the marines seems to
have some disciplinary hearing every
year i was thinking
but it would try your way
the knight is the most dangerous piece
on the board hello it can strike when
you least expect it
are you uh trying to be funny no
i can take you out whenever i want
how can you be at the wrong place at the
right time all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trick or treat mother
you